you've already taken a look at the
profile class but so far it doesn't
define an entity what you're going to be
doing now is going in and adding the
annotations to make it an entity you can
look for the places mark to do in
profile Java it's just a couple things
you need to do you need that to add the
annotation to indicate that the class is
an entity and when you've done that go
ahead and write the annotation here you
also need to add the annotation to
indicate that the user ID is the
property that's going to be used as a
unique identifier for profile entities
when you're done just go ahead and add
the annotation for identifying the
unique ID field here